by joining fond of our cart estimate is
currently I was taking a Porsche on to
the racetrack it's something many people
dream of but he expects that the new 911
turbo will be even dreamier than this
Porsche bike today he's meeting a
professional racer Porsches factory
driver yard Bergmeister with whom
they'll do a few laps but first let's
take a closer look at the elegant
speedster we'll be testing the 911 turbo
in the convertible version at speeds
over 120 km/h the front spoiler extends
to direct the airflow around the chassis
reducing uplift hi York Montes and Jorg
Bergmeister exchanged greetings Ghana
and off they go to the racetrack the 911
enjoys a long tradition at Porsche and
race driver York Bergmeister has been
involved in much of it
not just notes that this isn't the first
911 Yard has driven York says he first
drove a 964 in the 1994 Porsche Trophy
race and that he's driven every
generation since a 993 the 996 the 997
and now the 991 the current version of
the 911 Turbo produces 397 kilowatts and
660 newton meters of torque that
accelerates the car from 0 to 100
kilometers an hour in just 3.1 seconds
besides all not his ass York what's
special about the 911 turbo that's mine
at the top of your list is how much fun
it is to drive the 911 turbo has plenty
of power in every situation lots of
torque and a breathtaking top speed it's
just a lot of fun to drive whether on a
racetrack the highway or in city traffic
the car covers an impressive spectrum of
situations but ideas on to update this
I'm fine
the changes to the car's appearance are
minor noticeable probably only two
dyed-in-the-wool Porsche fans but the
output of the turbo and the Turbo S is
14 kilowatts or 20 horsepower higher
than their predecessors get the did not
assess your whether he can feel the
increased power of a new 991 when
driving toy klee been found the Oscars
baguette and how says your increased
torque and more horsepower are
definitely noticeable and the traction
is a little better too he says he can go
from zero to 100 kilometers an hour in
2.9 seconds specs that can leave you
speechless the roof of the 911 turbo
convertible opens in 13 seconds it
speeds up to 50 kilometers an hour the
interior is just as sporty as the
exterior materials are as high quality
as the price implies a selector on the
steering wheel lets the driver choose
from four driving modes the switch that
opens and closes the roof can be found
in the center console
this thing really moves explains York
the all wheel drive makes it hard to
make the card drifts as Montes you'd
have to take the car all the way to its
limits there goes one further you need
to take the 911 turbo to its limits and
shut off all the assists to even make
the car enter a drift but drifting is
something best done only by experts and
then mainly on the racetrack
the Porsches purchase price is also
beyond most people's limits the
convertible starts at almost one hundred
eighty eight thousand euros in Germany
compared with that the high expense for
fuel hardly matters Porsche says the 911
Turbo burns an average of nine point
three liters per 100 kilometers but
consumption and everyday driving is
probably much higher not to mention when
you pull out all the stops and put this
performer through its paces